ich rufe nun auf die Tagesordnungspunkte
7a und 7b
Beratung des Antrags der Fraktion der
cdu/csu mit dem Titel für Humanität und
Ordnung in der asyl- und
Flüchtlingspolitik Kommunen in der
Migrationspolitik unterstützen
Forderungen aus dem kommunalgipfel
Umsetzen so wie die Beratung des Antrags
der Fraktion Die Linke mit dem Titel aus
der Aufnahme der Ukraine flüchteten
lernen für einen echten
Paradigmenwechsel in der Asylpolitik
über den Antrag der Fraktion der cdu/csu
werden wir später namentlich abstimmen
ja meine Damen und Herren zwei völlig
unterschiedliche Anträge aus zwei
Oppositionsfraktionen stehen jetzt hier
auf dem Plan zur Asyl und
migrationspolitiker Bundesamt für
Migrationen Flüchtlinge wurden im
vergangenen Jahr 218.000 Asylanträge in
Deutschland bestellt im ersten Teil
diesen Jahres sind es schon 81000 das
sind 83% mehr als im Vorjahr zu dem
Zeitpunkt und viele Länder und vor allen
Dingen die Kommunen stoßen mittlerweile
wieder an ihre
Kapazitätsgrenzen die
Oppositionsfraktionen dringend hier auf
verschiedene Änderungen und darum geht
es jetzt sicherlich bei Andrea Lindholz
die zunächst für die CDU CSU sprechen
wird
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin meine sehr
geehrten Damen und Herren liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen unsere Kommunen
befinden sich spätestens seit Herbst in
einer erneuten schweren migrationskrise
allein in den vergangenen Monaten kam
fast 200.000 Asylbewerber nach
Deutschland und seit Beginn des
ukrainekrieges haben wir rund eine
Million ukrainische Flüchtlinge
aufgenommen das war und das ist eine
herausragende humanitäre Leistung
unserer Kommunen und ich möchte heute
allen Verantwortlichen und allen Helfern
vor Ort den größten Dank und Respekt
aussprechen
und gerade weil wir in Deutschland auch
in Zukunft tatsächlich schutzbedürftigen
Menschen helfen wollen ist unser Antrag
heute so wichtig denn unsere Kommunen
sind längst am Limit es fehlt am
Wohnraum an Kitaplätzen an Ärzten und am
vielen mehr und in dieser Lage hätten
die Bürgermeister und Landräte in
Deutschland eine Bundesregierung bitte
er nötig die aus Respekt vor ihrer
Leistung und der Lage vor Ort
pragmatisch handelt aber das Agieren der
aktuellen Bundesregierung ist von zwei
Dingen geprägt von
Realitätsverweigerung und
Respektlosigkeit
und ich gebe Ihnen drei Beispiele für
die Realitätsverweigerung dieser
Regierung im Oktober letzten Jahres
bietet Frau bundesinnenministerin Feser
den Ländern gerade einmal 4000 weitere
unterbringungsplätze des Bundesamt an
dieser in dieser Zeit kommen genauso
viele Asylbewerber jede Woche nach
Deutschland im November bestreitet Frau
Feser die große migrationskrise in
unserem Land und im Februar diesen
Jahres behauptet sie
Flüchtlinge sein für den Wohnungsmarkt
kein Problem denn das keine
Realitätsverweigerung ist
ich nenne Ihnen auch
drei Respektlosigkeit dieser Regierung
Bundesregierung hat keinen Respekt vor
den Ländern und Kommunen seit einem
Dreivierteljahr wiegeln Bundeskanzler
Scholz und Frau Feser die Forderung der
Kommunen nach mehr Geld und mehr
Unterstützung ab und den Gipfel setzt
Frau Feser noch im April oben drauf sie
kritisiert die Kommunen für Ihre
finanziellen Forderungen diese
Bundesregierung hat keinen Respekt vor
den Verantwortlichen und den Helfern vor
Ort nach dem zweiten flüchtlingsgipfel
im Februar wurden vier Arbeitskreise
eingesetzt und die haben tatsächlich
gearbeitet die haben nämlich
Handlungsempfehlungen gegeben wie man
besser bei der Unterbringung bei den
Finanzen Vorankommen kann sie haben klar
eine Forderung nach einer Beschränkung
der irregulären Migration und verstärkte
Rückführungen gefordert dieser Bericht
liegt seit einer Woche vor und was ist
passiert zum einen nichts und zum
anderen hat dieser Bericht das Licht der
Öffentlichkeit bis jetzt nicht erblickt
und schließlich hat diese
Bundesregierung auch keinen Respekt vor
der Öffentlichkeit und das betrifft
besonders die SPD denn Frau Feser und
Vertreter der SPD behaupten doch allen
Ernstes aktuell kämen acht von zehn
Migranten aus der Ukraine und liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen das ist
schlicht und ergreifend falsch
wir haben das getan was der
Bundeskanzler und diese Regierung längst
hätte tun müssen wir haben zu einem
kommunalgipfel hier nach Berlin
eingeladen Ende März wir haben uns
parteiübergreifend mit Vertreterinnen
und Vertretern der Kommunen unterhalten
wir haben mit ihnen über die Realität
gesprochen und wir haben Ihnen damit
auch Respekt gezollt und aus diesem
Treffen ist unser heutiger Antrag
entstanden und wir fordern ganz klar als
kurzfristige Maßnahmen eine stärkere
Unterstützung der Kommunen bei den
Finanzen eine stärkere Unterstützung bei
der Unterbringung eine bessere
Unterstützung des Ehrenamtes eine rasche
und spürbare Reduzierung der irregulären
Migration wir fordern endlich mehr
sichere Herkunftsstaaten auszuweisen als
Stoppsignal zum Beispiel an die
margret-staaten wir fordern den
sofortigen Stoff freiwillige
Aufnahmeprogramme zum Beispiel ist immer
noch laufenden aufnahmeprogramms
Afghanistan und wir fordern
notifizierte europäischen notifizierte
Lage angepasste und punktuelle
Grenzkontrollen an der deutschen Grenze
und wir brauchen auch Mittel und
langfristige Entlastung dazu gehört das
gemeinsame europäische Asylsystem das
auch Deutschland nützt und dazu gehört
es dass die Sozialstandards in der
Europäischen Union für Asylbewerber
endlich angeglichen werden und das nur
dort Leistungen bezogen werden wo die
Länder auch zuständig sind
und ich will Ihnen noch etwas sagen was
die
kommunenparteiübergreifend uns ganz klar
mitgegeben haben wir sollen auch an
manchen Stelle zurückkehren zu
Sachleistungen und das empfehle ich uns
an dieser Stelle ganz deutlich auch wenn
das manchmal mit mehr Aufwand verbunden
ist auch das ist ein Signal in die
Herkunftsländer wir fordern
ist die Bundesregierung und die SPD vor
allen Dingen endlich ihre
Realitätsverweigerung und
Respektlosigkeit ablegt die Kommunen
unterstützt und sie alle haben die
Möglichkeit unserem Antrag heute
zuzustimmen das wäre eine echte
Unterstützung und eine echte
Unterstützung auch für die Kommunen
vielen Dank
Andrea Lindholz die Stefan und der
Fraktionsvorsitzende für den Bereich hat
hier noch einmal den Antrag der CDU CSU
quasi Umrissen darin fordert die Union
die Kommunen dauerhaft finanziell zu
unterstützen ihre reguläre Migration
Einhalt zu gebieten und weitere Staaten
wie die magier-staaten und Georgien als
asylrechtlich sichere Herkunftsstaaten
einzuschätzen
gisan Yüksel jetzt für die SPD
aufgenommen hat dass wir Menschen aus
anderen Ländern der Welt Asyl gewähren
wenn sie vor Krieg und Gewalt fliehen
ist ein großer Akt der Menschlichkeit
viele Menschen viele Menschen helfen
diesen Kraftakt zustimmen ob als
ehrenamtliche oder als hauptamtliche all
diesen Helfern möchte ich danke sagen
danke für so viel Hilfsbereitschaft und
Engagement
sie zeigen die Nächstenliebe die die
Union in ihrem vorliegenden Antrag nur
Zuschauer stellt wie können Sie sich auf
nächste Liebe Berufe Liebe Union während
ihrer Ministerpräsident und
stellvertretender Bundesvorsitzender
Michael Kretschmer sogar das
Aufnahmeprogramm von afghanischen
ortskräften in Frage stellt
als Mitglied im Untersuchungsausschuss
Afghanistan darf ich Sie daran erinnern
afghanische ortskräfte haben oft und
über viele Jahre mit und für die
Bundeswehr gearbeitet wegen dieses
Engagements sind sie in großer Gefahr
sie zu schützen ist unsere moralische
Verpflichtung
solche Forderungen der Union leben wir
ab stattdessen arbeiten wir an konkreten
Lösungen wir haben bereits Maßnahmen
umgesetzt um die fluchtmigration nach
Deutschland zu stärken und zu ordnen
dazu zählen nicht nur die
Vorübergehenden Grenzkontrollen wir
haben erstmals einen
sonderbevollmächtigen für
migrationsabkommen eingesetzt er wird
dafür sorgen dass Herkunftsländer ihre
Landsleute ohne asylanspruch wieder
aufnehmen
viele viele
beschleunigen die Asylverfahren schon im
vergangenen Jahr konnte das BAMF die
Zahl der Asylentscheidungen deutlich
steigern und seit diesem Jahr sorgen wir
mit einem Gesetz zu dem für weniger
Bürokratie und schnellere Entscheidungen
und in der EU drängt unsere
Innenministerin anders als ihr
unionsvorgänger entschlossen auf ein
gemeinsames europäisches System mit
einheitlichen Standards und
solidarischer Verteilung sie sehen nach
Jahren der unionsblockaden schaffen wir
endlich Lösungen
meine sehr geehrten Damen und Herren
gerade die Städte und Gemeinden leisten
großartiges und geflüchtete aufzunehmen
zu versorgen und unterzubringen sie
tragen so die große Last dieser
gesamtgesellschaftlichen Aufgabe deshalb
lassen wir die Kommunen nicht alleine so
hat der Bund im vergangen ja 4,4
Milliarden Euro bereitgestellt und
weitere 2,75 Milliarden Euro für dieses
Jahr die Kommunen erwarten zu Recht dass
die Länder diese bundesmitte auch
vollständig an weiterleiten das Geld
muss endlich vor Ort ankommen
der Bund entlastet die Länder und
Kommunen auch in einem weiteren Punkt
geflüchtete aus der Ukraine können
nämlich Leistungen der Grundsicherung
erhalten das sind Kosten die weit
überwiegend vom Bund getragen werden
doch damit nicht genug als Bund wollen
wir weiter unterstützen deshalb arbeiten
wir konkret an einer altschuldenlösung
für die Kommunen auch in meinem
Heimatland Nordrhein-Westfalen sind
viele verschuldete Städte vom
Strukturwandel betroffen sie können sie
nicht aus eigener Kraft aus den
Altschulden befreien sie brauchen gerade
in der aktuellen Lage die besondere
Unterstützung von Bund und Ländern Liebe
Union hier können Sie zeigen ob sie die
notwendige Grundgesetzänderung mittragen
um so den belasteten Kommunen zu helfen
meine sehr geehrten Damen und Herren wir
schaffen gute Regeln zur Steuerung der
Migration wir lassen Städte und Gemeinde
nicht allein seit dem letzten
flüchtlingsgipfel Arbeiten Bund Länder
und Kommunen noch enger zusammen
Bundeskanzler Olaf Scholz hat schon
frühzeitig weitere Gespräche mit den
Ländern angekündigt und nun für den 10
Mai zu
sonderministerpräsidentenkonferenz
eingeladen
auf diese verlässliche und enge
Zusammenarbeit kommt es an denn nur
gemeinsam können wir den humanitären
Kraft der meistern vielen Dank
weil das Frau jüchsel gerade
angesprochen hat in dem Antrag der Union
wird nicht die Aufnahme von Bundeswehr
ehemaligen bundeswehrhelfen aus
Afghanistan kritisiert sondern das
freiwillige Aufnahmeprogramm was ist
nämlich auch gibt wo NGOs in Afghanistan
festlegen wer nach Deutschland kommen
soll und wer nicht Bernd Baumann jetzt
für die AFD der Parlamentarischen
Geschäftsführer meine Damen und Herren
eine wichtige elementare Ebene der
deutschen Politik rebelliert in einer
Macht und Schärfe wie es in der
Geschichte der Bundesrepublik noch nie
da war es sind die Chefs unserer über
10.000 Städte Gemeinden und Landkreise
in Deutschland die sich verbünden die
täglich große Verantwortung tragen sie
sind ist die überall vor Ort die
konkrete Politik machen sie sieht an
direktesten mit der Realität
konfrontiert sie sehen an
unmittelbarsten wo die Probleme liegen
und sie kriegen hautnah mit welche
Politik gut ist und welche schlecht und
die jetzige Migrationspolitik halten sie
für katastrophal meine Damen und Herren
Kommunalpolitiker Handeln weniger
ideologisch sind näher am Bürger wie
sagte selbst ein grüner ein grüner
Landrat jetzt im ZDF wörtlich wir müssen
Kontrolle darüber haben wer zu uns kommt
er sagt weiter der grüne Ausgangspunkt
meiner Arbeit ist nicht die Partei ist
nicht die grüne Blase und wenn am Ende
Grenzzäune notwendig sind dann sei das
für ihn auch okay daher ist es richtig
das Spitzenvertreter unserer gut 10.000
Kommunen jetzt ein sofortiges
Maßnahmenpaket verlangen sie fordern
effektive Sicherung der EU-Außengrenzen
gegen den illegalen Ansturm aus Orient
und Afrika von Migranten die hier
überhaupt keine schutzberechtigung haben
sie fordern wenn das nicht funktioniert
sofortige Kontrollen an unseren
deutschen Landesgrenzen meine Damen und
Herren deshalb bisher nur die AFD
gefordert wir haben Recht behalten die
Politiker vor Ort bestätigen uns
aber die fordern ja noch mehr
einreiseverweigerungen Zurückweisung an
den deutschen Grenzen sogar das Auslesen
von Handydaten um herkunftsdeutscher zu
überführen so sieht moderne
Migrationspolitik aus Länder wie
Dänemark und Schweden machen das längst
vor in Deutschland fordert das nur die
AFD und das seit Jahren und jetzt auch
noch die Landräte und Bürgermeister
richtig so meine Damen und Herren der
mittlerweile weiß auch der Großteil der
Bevölkerung Migranten sind allzu oft
keine Bereicherung und auch oft keine
Fachkräfte allzu oft sondern oft eine
schwere Belastung für die gesamte
Gesellschaft meine Damen und Herren
all das zeigt wir sind wir sind die
einzigen Verbündeten der wackeren
Kommunalpolitiker nicht sie von der CDU
mit ihrem heutigen Antrag sie behaupten
heuchlerisch sie würden die Forderungen
der Kommunalpolitiker unterstützen dabei
haben sie doch 16 Jahre lang eine
Regierung genau das Gegenteil getan sie
haben Vertreter dieser Forderungen auch
noch als rassistisch und rechtsradikal
gebrandmarkt und wenn cdu-landräte jetzt
Politik für die bürgerverordnung machen
wollen geht das eben nur mit den
demokratisch gewählten Volksvertretern
vor Ort ihre Forderung auch unterstützen
das geht also nur mit der AFD meine
Damen und Herren deshalb wollen immer
mehr Landräte und Bürgermeister mit der
AFD zusammenarbeiten aber sofort fallen
ihnen cdu-funktionäre in den Rücken
Friedrich Merz wie lieber drei Partei
taktisch Brandmauer einziehen er will
lieber den Grünen gefallen und so
kriegen die Landräte und das Volk vor
Ort wie Martin Luther sagen würde aufs
Maul gehauen wenn sie so wenn Sie diese
Beschlüsse umsetzen wollen das beweist
dass die CDU die Hilfe rufen der
Kommunalpolitiker nicht hört die sind
ihnen Wahrheit völlig egal meine Damen
und Herren es gibt Mehrheiten für eine
vernünftige Migrationspolitik und die
Brandmauern werden fallen zuerst auf
kommunaler Ebene dann in den Ländern die
gestern in Berlin und demnächst auch im
Bund
[Applaus]
die nächste Rednerin hier in der Debatte
kommt von den Bündnisgrünen vieles Polat
heute morgen noch im Phoenix Interview
sie ist eine der parlamentarischen
Geschäftsführerin der Bündnis
dann dieser Antrag der Union scheint
etwas gerade rücken zu wollen sie
beginnen mit einem Bekenntnis zum
christlichen Menschenbild der
Mitmenschlichkeit der Nächstenliebe als
wenn sie ein Zeugnis ablegen wollten vor
der spaltenen Rhetorik die dann folgt
meine Damen und Herren
uneingeschränkt für das Flüchtlingsrecht
einzutreten heißt nicht zu trennen das
Flüchtlingsrecht muss für alle
geflüchteten gleichermaßen gelten Herr
Hoffmann unabhängig von der Herkunft
hier und an den Außengrenzen
meine Damen und Herren
ich frage die Kolleginnen ist es
mitmenschlich Aufnahmeprogramme zu
beenden und damit vor allem den
besonders schutzbedürftigen bedrohen
bedrohten JournalistInnen Anwältinnen
Menschenrechtsaktivisten aus Afghanistan
den sicheren Zugang zu uns zu verweigern
nein das ist nicht mitmenschlich meine
Damen und Herren eine
abschottungsstrategie ist keine Lösung
sie nimmt lebensbedrohliche Situation
von Menschen billigend in Kauf und die
Diffamierung und Stigmatisierung von
schutzbedürftigen hat nichts mit
Humanität zu tun das ist
unverantwortliche Politik Politik die
spaltet wo sie integrieren sollte
die diese Koalition setzt sich deshalb
für sichere Fluchtrouten und für
humanitäre Aufnahmeprogramme ein von
denen vor allem die schutzbedürftigen
Gruppen profitieren
und meine Damen und Herren wenn der
Präsident der Diakonie Sachsen die
Forderung nach einem nach eines
Aufnahmestopps für afghanische
ortskräfte ihres Parteifreundes
und Ministerpräsidenten Kretschmer als
unethisch bezeichnet dann hat er einfach
recht
meine Damen und Herren ist es
mitmenschlich ist es mitmenschlich
Menschen in sogenannten zentralen
ankerzentren teilweise über Jahre zu
isolieren nein das ist es nicht mit der
Rückkehr zu ihrer Forderung nach den
gescheiterten ankerzentren greift die
Union in die flüchtlingspolitische
Mottenkiste und deshalb
und deshalb ist es richtig dass diese
Koalition diesen bayerischen
rohrkrippierer beendet hat meine Damen
und Herren das Ziel ihre ankerzentren
Asylverfahren zu beschleunigen und den
Betroffenen schneller Gewissheit über
den Flüchtlingsschutz zu ermöglichen
wurde eben nicht erreicht im Gegenteil
für den Großteil der geflüchteten hat
sich die Verweildauer in diesen
großunterkünften deutlich verlängert
und nur um nur um einmal eine Zahl zu
nennen im Jahr 2022 lag die
Bearbeitungsdauer bis zu einer
behördlichen Entscheidung in
ankerzentren vor allem in Bayern
deutlich über dem Durchschnitt mit 8,2
Monaten im Vergleich zu allen anderen
Einrichtungen
wer die Effizienz und damit
notwendigerweise die Qualität der
Asylverfahren steigern möchte sorgt
dafür dass die Menschen vorher gut
informiert sind über ihre Rechte
und die kürzlich eingeführte unabhängige
asylverfahrensberatung wird hierzu
sicherlich ihren Beitrag leisten meine
Damen und Herren
wer bei Familienangehörigen oder
Freunden unterkommen darf wird mit
diesen furchtbaren traumatischen
Ereignissen und der Trennung von Vätern
Brüdern und Partner in leichter fertig
als in einer zentralen Unterkunft dies
gilt insbesondere für Kinder da sollten
wir uns doch eigentlich alle einig sein
deshalb sind wir für die Streichung der
wohnsitzauflage die das genau verhindert
und das wird ja auch jetzt durch das BMI
geprüft auf Vorschlag eines
arbeitsplasters beim flüchtlingsgipfel
vielen Dank dafür Frau Ministerin
wer einen un
eingeschränicherungsschutz erhält kann
auch eine psychologische Versorgung in
Anspruch nehmen wer den Zugang zu
Integration Sprachkursen von Anfang an
bekommen kann die Sprache schneller
erlernen wer keinem Arbeitsverbot
unterliegt kann sein Leben
selbstbestimmt gestalten und unserer
Gesellschaft etwas zurückgeben meine
Damen und Herren das ist unsere Antwort
unsere Auftrag und unser Anspruch
mit dem flüchtlingsgipfel im Frau Polat
gestatten sie eine Zwischenfrage oder
Zwischenbemerkung vom Kollegen Hoffmann
nein mit dem flüchtlingsgipfel im
Kanzleramt wo die die Notwendigkeit
dieser integrationsoffensive für
geflüchtete zwar hervorgehoben ein
gesamtstaatliches Bekenntnis das für
alle geflüchteten gleichermaßen gilt
fehlt allerdings bisher im Gegenteil im
Moment wird denjenigen Raum gegeben die
von Begrenzung und Obergrenzen sprechen
von Abschiebung von Perspektiven von
Missbrauch statt vom miteinander deshalb
bin ich den
integrationsministerinnen der Länder
dankbar dass sie sowohl beim
flüchtlingsgipfel als auch bei ihrer
Fachkonferenz in dieser Woche die
Perspektive der Integration der Chancen
in den Mittelpunkt ihrer Beschlüsse
gestellt haben
die Aufnahme und Versorgung von rund
einer Millionen geflüchteter aus der
Ukraine zusätzlich zu Schutzsuchenden
aus anderen Ländern ist unbestritten
eine enorme Herausforderung die Kommunen
leisten mit Unterstützung des Haupt-
es bedarf daher auch eines erneuten
Signals des Kanzlers vor der anstehenden
Ministerpräsidentenkonferenz zur
angemessenen finanziellen Unterstützung
der Kommunen mit dem Ziel einer fairen
Kostenteilung zwischen dem Bund und den
Bundesländern diese Zusagen
die Zusagen aus dem letzten Jahr müssen
eingelöst werden so steht es im übrigen
auch im Koalitionsvertrag für die
Unterbringung sind die Länder zuständig
Herr Kollege Hoffmann
das bedeutet für uns das Angebot aber
auch für Integrationskurse nicht nur
weiterhin verlässlich bedarfsgerecht zu
finanzieren Frau Ministerin sondern wir
müssen die Integrationskurse und das
kurzsystem entbürokratisieren
Berufsabschlüsse müssen schneller
anerkannt werden und für den
Bürokratieabbau zu Entlastung der
Ausländerbehörden Frau Lindholz hat im
übrigen der Deutsche Städtetag gute
Vorschläge beim flüchtlingsgipfel
eingebracht und diese werden schon jetzt
von der Koalition in die laufenden
gesetzgebungsprozesse eingearbeitet und
das wird in jedem Fall zu Entlastung
beitragen
meine Damen und Herren wir achten die
Menschenrechte und nicht zuletzt auch
die Verfahrensrechte und liebe
Kolleginnen der Union Abschottung und
abschränkung haben nichts mit den
tatsächlichen Herausforderungen bei der
aufnahmeversorgung und Integration von
Schutzsuchenden zu tun
[Applaus]
16 Jahre haben sie das versucht das gilt
auch für den Ruf nach mehr Abschiebung
Menschen deren Asylantrag abgelehnt
wurde sind aus den verschiedensten
Gründen geduldet weil sie sich in einer
Ausbildungs-
eine eine Rechtsänderung die sie mit
geschaffen haben weil sie von ihren
Botschaften schlichtweg keine Pässe
erhalten können das Beispiel Eritrea
weil es von den Bundesländern einen
faktischen Stopp gibt von Abschiebung
zum Beispiel nach Syrien nach
Afghanistan und
in den Iran und der Großteil dieser
Menschen sind im übrigen Kinder
Jugendliche und Menschen im
erwerbsfähigen Alter diese Menschen
wollen sie abschieben das lehnen wir ab
wir brauchen darüber auch eine
politische Antwort die Chancen bietet
und letztendlich für uns alle
Perspektiven öffnet deshalb meine Damen
und Herren das chancenaufenthaltsrecht
ist dafür das beste Beispiel und wir
haben bei uns in Niedersachsen Frau
Ministerin vor allem auch
Anträge zum Chancen Aufenthaltsrecht von
jesidenten jetzt die unter Duldung leben
die wir eben nicht abschieben wollen wie
es die Union scheinbar tun will meine
Damen und Herren weitere Reformen beim
Spurwechsel werden folgen die Reform der
Ausbildungs-
herzlichen Dank dafür Frau Ministerin
viele geflüchtete wollen arbeiten sie
dürfen es aber nicht deshalb werden wir
auch die absurden Arbeitsverbote im
Aufenthaltsrecht ohne Ausnahmen
abschaffen
lassen Sie uns gemeinsam den aktuellen
Herausforderungen begegnen gemeinsam
geschlossen und entschlossen mitmachen
bei einer integrationsoffensive die
nicht nur den geflüchteten gilt sondern
uns allen einer
menschenrechtsorientierten Politik die
das Grundrecht auf Asyl nicht in Frage
stellt das ist Mitmenschlichkeit und
Nächstenliebe ich danke Ihnen für Ihre
Aufmerksamkeit
man muss aber dennoch sagen dass man mal
über Geld reden muss 29,8 Milliarden
Euro wurden veranschlagt für Flüchtlinge
und flüchtlingsbezogene Ausgaben im
vergangenen Jahr dies hier sollen es
auch wieder 26,6 Milliarden sein und am
10 Mai im Kanzleramt wird sicherlich die
Frage der Kosten auch eine wichtige
Rolle spielen Klara Bünger jetzt für die
Linke die bringen ja auch einen Antrag
hier ein und sagen wie man mit den
Ukraine Flüchtlingen umgeht sollte man
mit den anderen auch umgehen
denn ich hatte ihn mir nach den
Äußerungen von März Kretschmer und Co in
den letzten Tagen noch schlimmer
vorgestellt immerhin wenn Sie sich zum
Recht auf Asyl das muss man ja auch mal
positiv hervorheben allerdings
interessant ist zu den Kommunen steht
gar nicht so viel drin also der
forderungsteil hat es aber allerdings in
sich sie fordern im wesentlichen eine
Begrenzung der Aufnahme von geflüchteten
und eine Reduktion Zitat irregulärer
Migration dabei hantieren sie mit
Halbwahrheiten und Fake News zum
Beispiel behauptet die Union wieder
einmal es würden sehr viele Menschen
nach Deutschland kommen die
offensichtlich keinen Schutzanspruch
hätten das ist
voll verfallen weil die bereinigte
schutzquote des BamS erreichte letztes
Jahr sogar ein rekordwerk von über 70%
, und was soll eigentlich irreguläre
Migration bedeuten alle Asylsuchenden
müssen doch zunächst er regulär
einreisen weil es keine legalen
Fluchtwege gibt die dürfen dafür aber
nicht kriminalisiert werden und da steht
auch ganz klar in der Genfer
Flüchtlingskonvention das haben sie wohl
vergessen
ein Großteil von ihnen bekommt dann auch
Schutz am Ende ja wenn sie davon
sprechen irreguläre Migration reduzieren
zu wollen meinen sie doch eigentlich
Obergrenzen für Asylsuchende und das ist
nicht nur unmenschlich sondern auch
rechtswidrig
die Union die Union instrumentalisiert
ich höre Ihnen nicht nur zu ich lese
auch ihre Anträge und da steht ziemlich
viel von Abschottung drin die Union
instrumentalisiert die tatsächlichen
Probleme von Kommunen um mehr
Abschiebung und eine weitere Abriegelung
der Grenzen voranzutreiben diese Rechte
Stimmungsmache auf dem Rücken der Schutz
Suchende ist nicht nur ganz auf
unterster auf ganz unterster Stufe
sondern hilft auch keine einzigen
Kommune wir hingegen wir die LINKE
fordert dass alle Kosten vollumfänglich
vom Bund erstattet werden soll
und schlimm ist besonders schlimm ist
dass vieles von dem was die Union
fordert schon längst Wirklichkeit ist
oder bald Realität werden könnte und
ohne uns linke würden wir über diese
Realität gar nicht sprechen sie von der
Union fordern verpflichtende
grenzverfahren an der Außengrenze aber
das passiert doch schon genau das ist
Gegenstand der Reformvorschläge für das
Asylsystem auf EU-Ebene und SPD Grüne
und FDP tragen das mit obwohl damit die
massenhafte Inhaftierung von
Schutzsuchenden droht oder die Fiktion
der nicht Einreise bei den Menschen als
juristisch gar nicht eingereicht gelten
klingt wie eine Horror-Show der
Entrechtung ist aber Realität oder die
Forderung nach einem Stopp des
aufnahmeprogramms
faktisch hat die Bundesregierung doch
die Wiese Erteilung ein gefährdeter
Afghan längst ausgesetzt über die
Realität sollten wir doch mal sprechen
die Form der Abschreckungspolitik hat
noch nie dazu geführt dass Menschen sich
weniger auf den Weg machen denn Menschen
fliegen nicht wegen Anreizen sondern
weil Kriege repressive Regime die Folgen
des Klimawandels sie doch dazu zwingend
niemand verlässt sein zu Hause
freiwillig
und in unserem Antrag machen wir
Vorschläge für eine echte Menschenrechte
basierte Neuausrichtung der Asylpolitik
also eigentlich den
gepredigten Paradigmenwechsel als
Vorbild dienen doch die Erfahrung der
Aufnahme der Ukraine geflüchtete die
Ukraine kamen sofort Zugang zum
Arbeitsmarkt zu Sprachkursen sie durften
bei Angehörigen unterkommen das muss
doch für alle geflüchteten gelten
und Länder und Kommunen müssen sich
darauf einstellen dass dauerhaft
Asylsuchende nach Deutschland kommen
auch das gehört zu Realität denn Flucht
ist eine Realität die nicht einfach
verschwinden wird anstatt in
regelmäßigen Abständen Krisengipfel zu
veranstalten sollten und ungeordnete
Notlösung zu beschließen muss
langfristig in kommunale Infrastruktur
und Integration investiert werden und
der Bund muss die direkten und
indirekten Kosten für diese Aufnahme von
geflüchteten übernehmen da passiert aus
unserer Sicht noch viel zu wenig vielen
Dank
3,1 Millionen Flüchtlinge leben im
Moment in Deutschland darunter auch die
gut eine Millionen Flüchtlinge aus der
Ukraine andere ein großer Anteil sind
geduldet dass alles kostet viel Geld
aber die Linke hat die Lösung alle
Kosten erstattet der Bund Klara Bünger
jetzt hat gesprochen und Stefanie ist
jetzt der Redner für die FDP als
nächster hier im Parlament und Herren
die Migrationsdebatte wird bei uns in
Deutschland leider sehr sehr polarisiert
auf polarisierend geführt manchmal sehr
reflexhaft leider manchmal auch mit
einem sehr giftigen Ton in der Stimme
ich will Union nicht vorwerfen dass sie
die Modernisierung jetzt zum Ziel der
Matte haben man muss immer im Kopf haben
ich finde es auch gut dass Sie darauf
hinweisen pragmatisch sagt die Leute
Respekt die Debatte führen aber ich will
auch sagen ich fand es diese doch etwas
sehr pauschalen Schuldzuweisungen an die
Regierung man nehme die Kommunen nicht
ernst der Bund nichts man gibt kein Geld
eine Kommunen ich finde das sehr
pauschal Reflexe und auch nicht
zutreffend wenn man sich mal mal
anschaut ja sie hatten ihren ihren
Gipfel mit den Landräten im März aber
auch die Innenministerin hat am 16
Februar erstmals mit lernen und gemeint
mit den kommunalen Verbänden ein ein
Gipfel durchgeführt das ist so genau das
was sie was sie eigentlich wollen und
das ist das was was was auch richtig ist
dass wir zusammen mit den Kommunen auch
gemeinsam auf Dauer diskutieren welche
Plattform welche Gespräche notwendig
sind um die kommunalen Belange
einfließen zu lassen und es geschieht
hat Entschuldigung gestanden sie eine
Zwischenfrage dazwischen bemerken vom
Kollegen Hoffmann
Alexander Hoffmann CSU mit dem
Innenausschuss das gleiche sage mal was
anderes
Herr Kollege danke dass Sie die
Zwischenfrage zulassen und keine Angst
die Frage ist diesmal eine andere sie
haben gerade und da waren wir jetzt alle
überrascht sie haben gerade unseren
Antrag und das was wir heute an
Problemen auch der Kommunen geschildert
haben als
unzutreffend tituliert und uns hat es
deshalb erstaunt weil ich eigentlich
schon gedacht habe dass sie heute mal
endlich eine ganz andere Rede halten
denn immerhin hat hier Generalsekretär
der Generalsekretär der FDP gestern
gesagt wortwörtlich deutschland braucht
einen neuen Kurs in der
Migrationspolitik und weiter wir
brauchen dringend eine Migrationspolitik
die im Einklang mit der Realität ist im
Interesse unseres Landes ist und die
Sorgen der Bürger nicht
ignoriert
und da hatte ich mir eigentlich erhofft
dass sie heute dazu etwas ausführen und
vielleicht nutzen Sie die Gelegenheit
uns das mal zu erläutern also ich hatte
die Kollegin Lindholz angesprochen die
ist die Zuweisung macht das das war der
Bezug den ich herstellte aber dass das
was sie meinen ja wir brauchen insgesamt
ein ein Verständnis dass wir in dieser
Debatte 3
einander widersprechende Dinge
bestmögliche Einklang zu bringen
versuchen müssen ich würde mal das das
magische dreieinjektionsmusik nennen wir
brauchen wir brauchen natürlich wir
brauchen natürlich eine Politik die die
humanitären Verpflichtungen
völkerrechtliche verfassungsrechtliche
Verpflichtungen ernst nimmt und umsetzt
das ist das eine sozusagen das zweite
was wir brauchen ist eine Politik die
erkennt dass wir volkswirtschaftliche
spezifische geschäftliche Erfordernisse
haben die wir gestern auch hier mit
einer Verbesserung des eingangsgesetzes
für Arbeitskräfte vorgelegt haben wir
brauchen zum dritten eine Politik die
auch gesellschaftlich Akzeptanz schafft
und dies diese drei Dinge die ungeheuer
schwer in Einklang zu bringen sind die
müssen wir auch gemeinsam schaffen und
das ist das was unser Ziel sein muss das
scheint sie zu widersprechen die
einbetonen nur nur das eine die nur das
andere es ist unsere Aufgabe diese drei
drei schwierige Ende zu bringenden Dinge
gemeinsam zu diskutieren und Entdeckung
zu bringen das müssen wir versuchen das
will ich jetzt auch mal weit auszuführen
versuchen denn es gab ja nicht nur den
Gipfel am 16 Februar mit Innenminister
es wird auch am 10 Mai eine
MPG ein MPK des Bundeskanzler
Ministerpräsidenten geben bei der genau
auch wieder diese Dinge diskutiert
werden was die Finanzen betrifft
weiterer Punkt den sie Ansprachen in
diesem Jahr werden in der Summe über 26
Milliarden Euro aus dem Bundesland
Haushalt für Flüchtlingspolitik
ausgegeben werden und zwar den ganzen
Strang hindurch begonnen bei Maßnahmen
zur Fluchtursachen Bekämpfung bis hin zu
den situationsmaßnahmen über 12
Milliarden sind für die Länder und ihre
Kommunen vorgesehen gegenüber 2
Milliarden für die Kommunen direkt die
von den Ländern durchgeleitet werden
müssen also man kann doch nicht sagen
dass der Bund für Flüchtlingspolitik von
A bis Z auf den Kommunen kein Geld
bereitstellen würde das ist doch nicht
die Tatsache auch das
rechtskreiswechsel dazu führte dass
ukrainische Flüchtlinge vom aus
Bundesmitteln bezahlt wird hat die
Gemeinden ungeheuer entlastet also auch
das ist eine Maßnahme gewesen zu
Entlastung der Kommunen
oder ein anderer Punkt den sie auch
immer sehr kritisiert haben denn Chancen
Aufenthalt in den letzten Dezember
beschlossen haben das ist eine
pragmatische wie von ihnen verlangt
pragmatische Maßnahme gewesen um
einzuleiten dass Menschen die hier
geduldet sind die auf lange Zeit hier
leben ihren Weg finden außer
Sozialsystemen Arbeitsmarkt aus Staat in
Unterkünften hinein in privaten
Wohnungsmarkt das ist eine pragmatische
Rangehensweise lassen Sie mich in 3
Punkte ansprechen der
heftiges regiert wird momentan verlangt
der bei auf 47 Asylgesetz dass das
Personen die im Verfahren sind in
Aufnahmeeinrichtungen leben müssen das
ist an sich auch eine sinnvolle Maßnahme
weil dann das Verfahren dort in diesen
Einrichtungen getrieben werden kann in
der Lage der jetzt aber sind muss man
sich überlegen ob man nicht in Ausnahme
Situationen wie dieser wo eine Million
ukrainische Flüchtlinge und aus anderen
Ländern zusammen kommen nicht diese
Verpflichtung jedenfalls temporär
gelockert werden sollte es gibt auch
viele Menschen aus Syrien aus dem Irak
dem Iran aus Afghanistan die hier im
Land Bekannte Verwandte Freunde haben
oder hätten wo sie unterkommen können
das kann nicht mehr dauerlösungen sein
aber für eine Lage wie jetzt wo wir wo
die Kommunen wirklich aus allen Nähten
platzen kann das mal eine Lösung sein um
jedenfalls für eine gewisse Zeit die
der Platz nötig in den Kommunen zu
lindern es ist aber nicht nur der Bund
am Zuge muss es halt auch sagen auch bei
den Ländern sie sparen das Thema
Rückführungen Abschiebungen an auch bei
den Ländern gibt es noch Defizite was
das Thema abschiebe letzthaftplätze
betrifft das sind knapp 700
abschiebeplätze in Deutschland bei den
Länder bereitgestellt da bräuchten halt
auch die Länder etwas mehr Kapazitäten
die selber schaffen müssen und weil wir
Respekt vor den Kommunen angesprochen
haben ich finde es ein sehr sehr
wichtigen Punkt vor allem auch die
Ausländerbehörden die ja wirklich eine
schwierige Aufgabe haben in einem echten
Brennpunkt auch eine undankbare Aufgabe
ist niemanden recht machen können auch
da höre ich aus vielen Behörden dass ich
von ihren Landratsämtern ihren
Bürgermeister dann oft nicht hinreichend
ernst genommen fühlen und auch das muss
man immer wieder betonen und deutlich
machen diese
Beamte Mitarbeiter machen eine ungeheuer
schwierige komplizierte Aufgabe
bräuchten manchmal auch mehr
Unterstützung aus den Behörden selber
und das ist das was er leisten müssen
und anerkennen müssen dass wir eine
Gesamtaufgabe zustimmen haben der Bund
die Länder die Kommunen die Ehrenamtler
zusammen und deswegen würde ich mir
etwas weniger
Schuldzuweisungen etwas weniger Gift in
der Stimme weniger polenisierung
wünschen und mehr einzig dass wir hier
alle im gleichen Boot ist und gemeinsam
diese schwierige Aufgabe stemmen müssen
vielen Dank
der Bund hat sich bereit erklärt 2,82
Milliarden den Kommunen dieses Jahr zur
Verfügung zu stellen die Länder
beschweren sich zu Recht das Geld ist
noch nicht geflossen sie müssen
Vorleistung gehen denn das Geld soll aus
der umsatzsteuerbeteiligung kommen und
da fehlt schlicht und ergreifend die
Rechtsgrundlage manchmal liegt es auch
an solchen Dingen Alexander throm jetzt
der in politische Sprecher der CDU
CSU-Fraktion frau Präsidentin
Kolleginnen und Kollegen
das Ziel das Ziel unseres Antrages ist
den Kommunen hier gehört zu verschaffen
und keine einzige Rednerin keine einzige
Redner der Ampel hat die Belange der
Kommunen heute morgen angesprochen wenn
Sie uns nicht zuhören wollen dann hören
Sie doch auf den Präsidenten des
deutschen landkreis-tages Saga der heute
morgen in der Stuttgarter Zeitung gesagt
hat es sind Zustände die die Stimmung
kippen lassen liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen und erfordert weiter einen
neuen Kurs der Asylpolitik der Ampel die
der Landkreis der Präsident des
Landkreistages fordert diese nur die
Ampel hört darauf nicht liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen wir sind
in einer schweren migrationskrise dieses
Jahr werden wir Minimum 300.000
Asylanträge haben ohne die Ukraine die
Menschen kommen oben drauf on top auf
die hohe Zahl von Aufnahmen des letzten
Jahres und die Kommunen sind an der
Belange Belastungsgrenze angelangt und
die erste Großstadt Frau Kollegin Polat
hat bereits die Aufnahme verweigert
Hannover aus ihrem Bundesland mit einem
grünen Oberbürgermeister das ist der
Beweis auch bei den Grünen sind die
Möglichkeiten die Kapazitäten endlich
nur Sie hier in Berliner Raumschiff
haben des offensichtlich noch nicht
mitbekommen bei den Grünen liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen
und ja die Frau Feser hat im Februar zu
einem flüchtlingsgipfel eingeladen und
das einzige Ergebnis war dass man
Arbeitskreise gegründet hat und Wunder
die Arbeitskreise haben Ergebnis
geliefert die Kommunen und die Länder
haben Forderungen an die Bundesregierung
gestellt dieselbe Forderung ändern Sie
Ihren Linie in der Migrationspolitik sie
gefordert dass sie die Beschränkung der
wohnsitzauflage die sie vor kurzem
beschlossen haben wieder zurücknehmen
sie fordern mehr bundesligaschaften weil
die diese bisher geliefert haben siehe
Baden-Württemberg nicht geeignet sind
für die Unterbringung sie fordern
kurzfristige grenzschutzmaßnahmen an der
EU-Außengrenze wenn dies nicht möglich
ist was wohl absehbar ist kurzfristig
dann auch Binnengrenzkontrollen sie
fordern sichere Herkunftsländer sie
führen eine endlich eine eine
rückführungsoffensive und sie fordern in
dieser Hebel ja und Frau Kollegin Polat
und Herrn Thomas sie fordern auch
Einkaufszentren wieder einzuführen die
sie abgeschafft haben und sie vorne
genau das Gegenteil von dem was sie
gerade gesagt haben wir Bezug auf
Paragraph 47 als Ziel gesetzt sie
fordern dass die Menschen die
Flüchtlinge so lange im ankerzentrum und
Erstaufnahme Einrichtungen bleiben bis
geklärt ist ob sie eine
Bleibeperspektive haben und sie wollen
sie vorher verteilen das ist genau das
Gegenteil dessen was die Kommunen liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen
das gesamte Ergebnisprotokoll Frau
Ministerin ich kann es nicht anders
sagen ist eine schallende Ohrfeige der
Länder und der Kommunen für die
Asylpolitik der Ampel und von ihnen
und sie haben
vorletzte Woche die Grenzkontrollen zu
Österreich
richtigerweise verlängert
die Frage ist nur was der Unterschied
von Österreich zu Tschechien zur Schweiz
oder seit neuestem auch zu Polen ist in
einer einzelanfrage wurden wir diese
Woche die Zahlen für die
illegalen Grenzübertritte genannt sie
haben ja der Bundespolizei verboten
diese monatlich zu berichten also muss
man nachfragen in Polen plus 90% + 90%
im Vergleich zum Vorjahreszeitraum in
der Schweiz oder zur Schweiz plus
290% im Vergleich zum Vorjahreszeit und
deswegen meine Frage an die Ampel an sie
Frau Ministerin was ist das sachliche
Argument dass sie richtigerweise zu
Österreich die Grenzkontrollen
verlängern aber dieses nicht bei den
teilweise höher belasteten Grenzen
insbesondere auch bei Polen wurde
momentan
ebenfalls tun wir müssen sie handeln
hören Sie auf die Kommunen das ist das
Mindeste was hochgelassen Kommune
verlangen können herzlichen Dank
den politischen Sprecher der
Unionsfraktion war das Alexander throm
es antwortete innenpolitische Sprecher
der SPD-Fraktion Sebastian hartmann
ist der Kollege Sebastian Hartmann
SPD-Fraktion
sehr geehrter Herr Präsident meine sehr
geehrten Damen und Herren die Union hat
einen Antrag auf die Tagesordnung
gesetzt und suggeriert sie würde sich um
die Belange der Kommunen sorgen und
meine Damen und Herren ist gehört eine
gewisse Portion Unverfrorenheit und
geschichts Vergessenheit hinzu eine
solche Debatte hier anzustoßen wenn die
Union angesichts 16 Jahre lang schwarz
geführter Innenpolitik genau für diese
Lage hier verantwortlich ist
und das meine Damen und Herren ist eine
Dreistigkeit sondergleichen denn es ist
suggeriert dass in diesem Antrag außer
Problembeschreibung Ressentiments und
Spaltung irgendein Ansatz von Lösung
enthalten ist ich sage Ihnen sie
brauchen den Antrag nicht lesen und die
nichts konstruktives zu dieser Debatte
beizutragen
sie nehmen in den übrigen
ein sehr selektiven Blick der Realität
vor sie blenden aus dass wir in den
vergangenen Jahren und offensichtlich
wollen sie mit der Politik von merkel
und Seehofer abrechnen dass wir in der
Vergangenheit auch eine Sache geschafft
haben die sie heute nicht mehr tun
wollen es gibt eine
Verantwortungsgemeinschaft von Bund und
Ländern den Kommunen gegenüber das
wollen sie heute aber nicht mehr wissen
und die Forderung die sie an den Bund
richten richten sie in Wahrheit an
schwarz geführte Länder die ihrer
Verantwortung nicht nachkommt
erstens sind die Länder für das
Aufenthaltsrecht und den Vollzug und
damit auch Rückführungen zuständig das
richtet sich als Kritik an ihre Länder
und der Bund unterstützt hier zweitens
ist es so dass die Länder unterstützt
werden durch den Bund über den Weg der
umsatzsteueranteile bei der
Wohnraumförderung und auch Übernahme der
SGB II Kosten bei geflüchteten der
Ukraine alles das vergessen Sie der Bund
kommt seiner Verantwortung nach meine
Damen und Herren und Frau Lindholz wenn
sie schon über die Innenpolitik in
Deutschland sprechen dann sage ich ihnen
Horst Seehofer war immer auf
Tauchstation wir mussten ihn als
Sozialdemokratie dazu zwingen überhaupt
mit den Kommunen zu reden das hat
nämlich in der Vergangenheit nicht
stattgefunden und Horst Seehofer ist
niemals nach Brüssel gefahren hat sich
zu seinem Staatssekretären vertreten
lassen werden nennt sich besser als
erste Innenministerin die Fakten tun weh
meine Damen und Herren von der Union
aber sie können eine solche Debatte
nicht anstoßen sie praktisch führen sie
müssen sich das vorhalten lassen meine
Damen und Herren es ist Versagen der
unions Innenpolitik und es war Trauma
Bewältigung was ich hier machen aber wir
arbeiten dran wir lösen das pragmatisch
und wir spielen Länder Kommunen und Bund
nicht gegeneinander aus weil wir
ineinander nationalen Krise sind die
Putin verursacht hat kommen sie ihrer
Verantwortung als Opposition nach und
hören Sie mit diesen Mucks auf
und in den Zuständigkeiten Gefüge wenn
wir schon darüber reden es ist eine
Unverschämtheit das Länder die Mittel
die der Bund Ihnen zur Verfügung stellt
um die Kommunen zu unterstützen nicht
eins zu eins durchleitet auch das sind
schwarz geführte Länder geben sie
endlich das Geld weiter was wir als Bund
an die Kommunen geben
und wenn sich schon
ausblenden dass wir über 19,20
Milliarden in den vergangenen Jahren
Haushalt für Haushalt zur Verfügung
gestellt haben dann stelle ich Ihnen die
Frage warum in ihrem Antrag kein
einziger konstruktiver Lösungsvorschlag
ist wer hat es nicht geschafft auf
europäischer Ebene für ein gemeinsames
Asylsystem zu sorgen wer hat es nicht
geschafft dafür zu sorgen dass sie in
der Lage sind ein einheitliches
Asylverfahren durchzuführen dass
Deutschland hier andere Staaten
Unterstützung ist es ist ihre
Verantwortung meine Damen und Herren von
der Union der ganze Antrag richtet sich
an sie selbst und die größte und
Verschämtheit in dieser Geschichte ist
dass sie dieses Machwerk an die Kommunen
schicken aber sehr selektiv sehr hören
Sie mal Herr Kollege Hoffmann ich lese
ihn jetzt mal vor was die Kommunen ihrem
Antrag entgegengehalten haben sie haben
doch die Kommunen gebeten dazu stellt zu
nehmen dann zitiere ich mal aus dem
Freistaat Bayern
der Oberbürgermeister von Erlangen
schreibt anstatt auf ihren Antrag hin
anstatt für Gemeinsamkeit und
Solidarität einzustehen schürt die
Kampagne Angst und ressorttiments sie
propagiert Spaltung und Ausgrenzung wo
Eigentlichkeit und Zusammenarbeit
notwendig wäre und sie schließt mit den
Worten nicht in meinem Namen hören Sie
auf die Kommunen zu missbrauchen
können Sie auch die Kommunen zu
missbrauchen hören Sie auf die
Vergangenheit zu verklären sie haben die
Lage dabei geführt wir haben 300.000
geduldete Menschen in diesem Land mit
dauerduldung wir mussten ein Chancen
Aufenthaltsrecht einführen damit endlich
hier wieder Ordnung hinkommen und wenn
sie über Asyl und erwerbsmigration
sprechen dann ist es unverfroren dass
die Union die diese Lage verursacht hat
nun versucht die Kommunen zu
missbrauchen dass sie sich nicht schämen
ist die eigentliche Dreistigkeit in
dieser Debatte und daher möchte ich die
letzten Sekunden darauf verwenden mich
bei den Kommunen bei den Städten und
Gemeinden bei den Landkreisen zu
bedanken und für diese Debatte von der
Union zu entschuldigen wir unterstützen
Sie wir wollen pragmatische Lösungen und
wir werden das Spiel der Vergangenheit
nicht noch mal führen dass wir die
Ebenen gegeneinander ausspielen Bund und
Länder haben eine
Verantwortungsgemeinschaft das hat die
Ampel erkannt wir handeln der Rest hat
es nicht getan
der Oberbürgermeister der Stadt Erlangen
heißt Florian Josef Jannik ist dort seit
2014 Oberbürgermeister und o Wunder er
ist natürlich SPD-Mitglied nächster
Rednerin hier in der Debatte Carolin
Bachmann von der AFD
herr Präsident sehr geehrte Damen und
Herren
Liebe linke um es vorwegzunehmen ihr
Antrag ist ein einziges Bekenntnis zur
Abschaffung Deutschlands und deswegen
werden wir den ablehnen und sehr geehrte
Vertreter der Union ihr Antrag ist an
den Stellen sehr stark wo sie die
Forderungen der AFD übernommen haben
ansonsten ist der Antrag wie schon ihr
kommunalgipfel leider eine verpasste
Gelegenheit Politik für die
Einheimischen zu machen die Kommunen
fordern ganz deutlich eine Kehrtwende in
der Migrationspolitik sie hätten sie
Gelegenheit den Wunsch der Kommunen in
die Bundestag zu treten stattdessen
verlassen sie sich weitgehend auf den
Grenzschutz in der EU und die Verteilung
von Flüchtlingen in Europa sie hätten
dem eigenen dem eigenen Volk eine
Perspektive bieten können sie hätten
angesichts der strukturellen Überlastung
Deutschlands den sofortigen Stopp der
illegalen Massenmigration fordern können
stattdessen wollen Sie etwas begrenzen
und etwas reduzieren Liebe Union sie
wissen ist doch selbst das ist nicht
genug
sie hätten falsche Anreize für
fluchzuwanderungen vollständig benennen
und sich dagegen richten können
stattdessen forcieren sie den
schnelleren Ausbau von Unterkünften
Schulen und Kitas für Migranten in ihrem
Positionspapier fordern sie dann sogar
noch eine neue Bundesagentur und wenn
sie für Einwanderung deutschland ist für
Sie genau wie sie für Sie hier von der
Ampel nicht mehr das Land der Deutschen
sondern nur noch ein bundesauffangbecken
für die ganze Welt ihr Antrag wird
mitnichten
wir Antrag wird nicht den
grundsätzlichen Problem gerecht werden
nach wie vor Ströme Millionen von
Menschen aus aller Welt unkontrolliert
nach Deutschland ein letztes Jahr waren
es beinahe 1,5 Millionen Menschen das
entspricht der Bevölkerungszahl von
München der drittgrößten Zahl
Deutschlands Stadt Deutschlands
insgesamt leben in Deutschland bei einer
13,5 Millionen Personen mit
ausländischer Staatsbürgerschaft das
entspricht der Bevölkerungszahl von
Bayern dem zweitgrößten Bundesland die
Städte sind mittlerweile übervoll
mittlerweile sollte ihn eigentlich klar
sein wo die städtischen Wohnungsnot
herkommt nämlich aufgrund ihrer
ungezügelten migration
verabschieden schafft Wohnraum die
Lösung ist abschieben und die Grenzen
dicht zu machen mittlerweile ergießen
sich Hunderttausende von Migranten in
den ländlichen Raum und was ist die
Lösung von ihnen allen hier
containerdörfer und bald vielleicht
Plattenbauten für Migranten und eine
eigene soziale Infrastruktur für
Migranten das ist eine Sauerei geht am
Problem vorbei und wird die Kommunen
belasten und das ist mit uns nicht zu
machen
sehr geehrte Vertreter der Union werden
die Bundesregierung eine
Migrationspolitik nach dem Motto treibt
nach mir die Sinnflut halten Sie immer
noch die Schleusen auf dem sie haben
eben keine eigene Lösung für das
Migrationsproblem und die nachhaltige
Entlastung der Kommunen der Antrag ist
viel mehr eine Scheinlösung einer
Scheine Position die sich nicht ja weil
sie sich nicht von Merkel gelöst haben
immer noch nicht und das merken
mittlerweile alle Bürger die einzige
Lösung des migrationsproblems besteht in
einer konsequenten
Deutschland freundlichen Politik und die
bekommen die Bürger nur mit der AFD
sagt Carolin Bachmann die Union legt
genau wie die Linke hier einen Antrag
vor die Union fordert unter anderem die
Kommunen dauerhaft finanziell für diese
Aufgaben der Migration zu versorgen und
der nächste Redner kommt von der Union
ist der kommunalpolitische Sprecher der
Union und heißt Andrea
André Berg Heger so es ist richtig
sehr geehrter Herr Präsident liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen meine Damen und
Herren ich werde mich mal der
Perspektive der Kommunen im engeren
Sinne widmen und hoffe auch Herr Thomé
dass das nicht zu pauschal werden wird
eine beispiellos hohe Zahl an
Schutzsuchenden wurde in den letzten
Monaten von den Städten Gemeinden und
Landkreisen aufgenommen und das sind
Zeiten von akutem wohnmangel von
fehlenden Kitaplätzen und in Zeiten
eines ausgelasteten Bildungswesens eine
enorme Herausforderung in dieser
Situation unsere Kommunen das kann man
glaube ich gar nicht oft genug betonen
leisten dabei herausragendes und
deswegen an dieser Stelle großen Dank
hierfür
konkret konkret wird ja wird jedoch dass
Dilemma zwischen Humanität und
tatsächlichen Möglichkeiten vor Ort
immer größer
erstorientierungskurse Sprachkurse
Integrationskurse sind überlastet oder
kaum verfügbar der Bildungserfolg der
Kinder wird gefährdet Integration kann
unter solchen Rahmenbedingungen nicht
gut gelingen sie findet vielerorts
teilweise gar nicht mehr statt
deutschland muss sich aber auch in
Zukunft auf migrationssituationen durch
Krisen einstellen denn die
organisatorischen finanziellen und
bürokratischen Strukturen sind darauf
noch nicht ausreichend vorbereitet
zeitenwände liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen bedeutet für uns auch
Neuausrichtung der Migrationspolitik
die die Kommunen die Kommunen brauchen
in dieser Situation dringend dringend
Entlastung sie brauchen nicht nur aber
auch eine dauerhafte eine verlässliche
und eine angemessene finanzielle
Unterstützung insbesondere durch den
Bund aber natürlich auch durch die
Länder was heißt das dauerhaft wir
dürfen uns nicht jedes Mal von
flüchtlingsgipfel zu flüchtlingsgipfel
handeln verlässlich bedeutet die
Bundesregierung darf nicht immer wieder
nach Ausreden suchen warum eine
Unterstützung gerade nicht geht und vor
allen Dingen darf sie keine Gründe
Anführer anführen die nichts mit der
aktuellen Migrationssituation zu tun
haben denn die
Migrationssituation können die Kommunen
nicht beeinflussen die Bundesregierung
schon wie wir hier gehört haben
angemessen bedeutet eine Unterstützung
dass sie abhängig ist von den
tatsächlichen Flüchtlingszahlen und an
den tatsächlichen Kosten vor Ort
orientiert sein muss und die Gelder
müssen vom Bund eins zu eins
weitergeleitet werden
Grundlage für eine solche finanzielle
Unterstützung könnte das jahrelang
praktizierte seit 2015 aus meiner Sicht
bewährte aber Ende 2021 ausgelaufene
vier säulen-modell sein ich rufe da noch
mal in Erinnerung es gab eine
pro-kopf-zahlung für jeden Monat während
des Asylverfahrens von ermittelten nicht
geschätzten 670 Euro es gab zweitens
einen Festbetrag für unbegleitete
Minderjährige Asylbewerber die bedürfen
doch der intensiven Begleitung und diese
Situation gibt es nach wie vor es gab
eine Anerkennung der
Integrationsleistung vor Ort die
Integrationsleistung erfolgt über Jahre
in unterschiedlichsten Stufen die waren
Anfang zwei Milliarden Euro ist dann
über die Jahre abgeschmolzen worden von
700 Millionen über 500 Millionen und ist
jetzt eingestellt ist ausgelaufen aber
die kosten fallen noch nach wie vor an
und wir brauchen nicht so guter Letzt
die vollständige Übernahme der
Unterkunftskosten für anerkannte
Flüchtlinge orientiert
orientiert an den tatsächlichen
unterschiedlichen Kosten vor Ort denn
die variieren gewaltig und vor allen
Dingen inklusive Vorhaltekosten dann
bedarf es auch keiner Frau Ministerin
keiner Verwunderung warum die Kommunen
jetzt aktuell nicht mehr so viel
Wohnraum vorhalten können das hat
einfach zwei Gründe erstens es gab eine
Zeit da konnte Wohnraum gar nicht mehr
bezahlt werden von den Kommunen und
zweitens der liegt jetzt schlicht und
ergreifend nicht mehr vor diesem Problem
müssen wir uns mitnehmen derzeit gibt es
eine Pauschale für die Kommunen von 2,75
Milliarden Euro für drei für 2023 im
letzten Jahr waren es noch 3,5
Milliarden Euro für diese Kosten und das
bei steigenden Zahlen der Asylbewerber
und bei einer festen Bindung des
größtenteils dieser Kosten für
ukrainische Flüchtlinge das geht doch
nicht zusammen das passt doch nicht das
wird nicht aufgehen das weiß doch auch
die Bundesregierung
sehr geehrte Frau Ministerin das vier
Säulenmodell ist eine gute Grundlage für
die Ministerpräsidentenkonferenz im Mai
insgesamt soll unser Antrag ein Beitrag
dazu liefern eine zukunftsfeste
Migrationspolitik und zusätzlich unter
Anerkennung und Wertschätzung nicht
zuletzt der finanziellen Wertschätzung
der Leistung der Kommunen ohne sie wird
es nicht gehen vielen Dank für Freund
vielen Dank Herr Kollege Dr sagte der
als nächster Redner hat das Wort der
Kollege eine semmet ftp-fraktion
[Applaus]
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen ich danke ich
danke meinem Vorredner dass wir die
Diskussion jetzt wieder in etwas
vernünftige Bahnen vielleicht führen
können weil die Auseinandersetzung über
Probleme die wir nicht schnell lösen
können ist denke ich in mancherlei
Hinsicht nicht zielführend die Tatsache
dass wir möchte ich auch vorab sagen wir
leben in einer sehr disruptiven Welt wir
leben in einer globalisierten Welt und
es ist es ist Fakt dass Menschen sich in
Bewegung setzen und im Elend und der
Armut zu entfliehen und dass diese
Menschen auch bei uns hier ankommen wie
wir damit umgehen das ist unsere Sache
es nützt wenig immer nur zu adressieren
was sein müsste oder was getan werden
muss wir sollten konkrete Schritte
unternehmen um uns auf diesem Weg hin zu
bewegen
jeder von uns kennt die Situation in den
Kommunen und jeder kennt die
Diskussionen mit denen wir uns damit
auseinandersetzen müssen
das Thema kenne ich genauso und das
kennen wir alle aber wir sind wir stehen
doch nicht tatenlos hier sie fordern
maximale Dinge die teilweise gar nicht
realisierbar sind auf dem ersten
flüchtlingsgipfel des BMI wurden
Strukturen geschaffen die Bund Länder
und Kommunen miteinander verknüpfen die
geschaffenen Arbeitsgruppen setzen sich
intensiv mit diesen Problemen
auseinander und es werden auch
Fortschritte erzählt
nur so wir können nur durch eine
gemeinsame gemeinsames Arbeiten ein
Fortschritt erreichen und Probleme
tatsächlich lösen darüber hinaus das ist
schon gesagt worden der Bund fördert die
Kommunen und geflüchteten mit 12
Milliarden dieses Jahr an insgesamt im
Umfang von etwa 30 Milliarden das Geld
das dass die Verteilung des Geldes
obliegt den Kommunen und der
Verantwortung der Länder
der rechtskreiswechsel ist angesprochen
angesprochen worden auch dort werden die
Kommunen entscheidend entlastet auf der
Suche nach neuen Unterkünften hat der
Bund bereits 329 Objekte zur Verfügung
gestellt das sind etwa knapp 70.000
unterbringungsplätze mir ist wohl
bewusst dass das noch nicht genug ist
als aber das ist ein Schritt in die
richtige Richtung
letztes Jahr haben wir außerdem die
Asylverfahren deutlich beschleunigt
dadurch können Schutzsuchende auf der
einen Seite schneller in den
Wohnungsmarkt integriert werden das
entlastet die
erstaufnahmeeinrichtungen erheblich auf
der anderen Seite können dadurch auch
Rückführungen deutlich schneller
stattfinden sie werden jetzt sagen die
Situation ist aber trotzdem angespannt
und sie haben dann damit natürlich sie
haben damit natürlich Recht das ist uns
allen bewusst
doch der doch die Ausgangslage lässt
sich nicht nur durch kurzfristige
Maßnahmen lösen wir müssen dafür sowohl
unsere einwanderungs aber auch unsere
Asylpolitik ändern
nichts anderes nichts anderes haben wir
die ganze Zeit auch gesagt und nichts
anderes ist das womit wir uns auch
beschäftigen
zum einen zum einen muss ihre irreguläre
Migration natürlich abnehmen das werden
wir vor allem durch eine bessere
Sicherung der EU-Außengrenzen erreichen
im Idealfall sollen können vielleicht
schon Suchende oder sollen schon in
ihrem Eimer Heimatland einer Asylantrag
stellen können so können wir die
Behörden und Aufnahmekapazitäten in
Deutschland deutlich hinterlassen auch
die Rückführung abgelehnte asylbewerbung
muss schneller funktionieren das wird
von allen adressiert die Umsetzung
dessen ist problematisch und schwierig
das wissen wir auch alle aber wir
arbeiten daran zum anderen müssen wir
regulär zum anderen müssen wir reguläre
Einwanderung besser organisieren wir
brauchen Zuwanderung das möchte ich an
dieser Stelle noch noch mal ausdrücklich
sagen
anders werden wir werden wir die
Herausforderungen auf unserem
Arbeitsmarkt nicht meistern wer illegale
Einwanderung bekämpfen will muss auch
legale Zuwanderungswege schaffen
ich bin froh dass wir gestern begonnen
haben dass wir gestern begonnen haben
über das Fachkräfte Einwanderungsrecht
zu debattieren
das ist ein echtes Projekt was die FDP
sehr stark gewesen zum Schluss kommen
ich muss zum Schluss kommen deshalb muss
ich hier etwas abkürzen
einer Kollege sie müssen jetzt einfach
zum Schluss kommen sie haben jetzt noch
einen Satz da muss ich das Wort anziehen
Einsatz wir müssen stärker wir müssen
stärker die Integration in den
Arbeitsmarkt fördern und stärker
versuchen die Menschen schneller in die
Gesellschaft zu integrieren das ist mein
zentrales Anliegen ich danke für eure
Aufmerksamkeit vielen Dank Herr Kollege
damit
ich hätte
Abgeordneten Robert fahren
Robert Fahne war mal in der afd-fraktion
ist ausgetreten und einer der
fraktionslosen Abgeordneten hier im
Hohen Hause er hat jetzt das Rede Recht
hier im Parlament zu diesem Thema
sehr geehrter Herr Präsident sehr
geehrte Damen und Herren
die grenzenlose Einwanderungspolitik der
Ampel ist gescheitert und sie haben seit
2015 auch nichts dazu gelernt bei der
CDU sieht man erste Ansätze dass man
etwas dazugelernt hat aber jetzt kommt
es darauf an dass sie mal sich richtig
mit dem Problem beschäftigen und vor Ort
diese Probleme auch mal konsequent
angehen dass unsere Grenzen geschützt
werden und dass der Missbrauch in diesem
Bereich auch beendet wird
zweitens in Deutschland fehlen sie
700.000 Wohnungen
Neubauprojekte werden wegen
Preiserhöhungen bestiegener Bauzinsen
aufs Eis gelegt drittens erste Heime
setzen alte kranke und pflegebedürftige
auf die Straße weil mit Flüchtlingen
mehr Geld zu machen ist die Kommunen
brauchen schlichtweg mehr Geld man muss
ihnen helfen vierten zehntausende
Hotelzimmer sind belegt Komfort Hotel in
Weißensee projekthotel in Hamburg Nord
das ehemalige Rathaus in Wilmersdorf
alles was ein Dach hat wird zur
Flüchtlingsunterkunft gemacht sogar
turnhahn werden wieder zweckentfremdet 5
die Ampel setzt immer mehr Anreiz um
gering Qualifizierte anzuwerben während
qualifizierte deutsche das
landmassenhaft Verlangen verlassen
sechstens für die Entlastung der
Kommunen beiden asylkosten wird nicht
genügend Geld bereitgestellt aber 15
Milliarden Euro damit sehr lässige genug
Munition in der nächsten Offensive hat
siebten sie zerstören unsere
Energieversorgung vernichten
Industriearbeitsplätze und treiben
Mittelständler in Ruin sind eigenen
Einfamilienhausbesitzer mit der
wärmewendechaos 9 sie führen Deutschland
Schritt für Schritt in einen großen
Krieg gegen Russland tausende Kämpfer
bilden Sie aus und behaupten allen ernst
dass sie hätten mit diesem Krieg nichts
zu tun sie sind keine Kriegspartei das
ist Heuchelei hoch 3 meine Damen und
Herren spätestens bei den nächsten
Wahlen kann und muss dieser Unsinn
gestoppt werden die Ampel muss weg
vielen Dank
vielen Dank Herr Kollege der Auftritt
von Robert fahle fraktionslose
Abgeordnete hier im Deutschen Bundestag
der Kommunalwahl Migrationspolitik das
zwei Anträge von CDU CSU und Linke
werden hier beraten nächste Ritterin in
der Debatte Peggy hier Weg für die SPD
sehr geehrter Herr Präsident
sehr geehrte Damen und Herren sehr
geehrte Kolleginnen und Kollegen als ich
den Tagesordnungspunkt für heute gesehen
habe habe ich gedacht da möchte ich was
zu sagen also ich dann den Antrag
vorliegen hatte habe ich gedacht da muss
ich auch was zu sagen und als ich mit
dem Lesen des Antrags fertig war habe
ich gedacht oh Gott habe ich was
verpasst
denn wer diesen Antrag der Union ließ
der bekommt den Eindruck dass wir hier
überall in unhaltbaren Zuständen lieben
würden wenn ich nur das Deutschland aus
ihrem Antrag kennen würde dann würde ich
hier auch nicht unbedingt leben wollen
nun bin ich ja nicht nur
Bundestagsabgeordnete ich bin auch
Kreistagsabgeordnete und ich bin
Ratsfrau
und tatsächlich mache ich andere
Erfahrungen als das was in diesem Antrag
beschrieben wird in meinem Wahlkreis ist
die Lage nämlich insgesamt eher
entspannt wir bringen alle geflüchteten
unter und haben sogar vereinzelte
Kapazitäten frei aber um sich jetzt so
gehen dass meine Wahlkreis nicht nur ein
glücklicher Einzelfall ist habe ich noch
ein paar Kolleginnen und Kollegen
gefragt aus diesem Hohen Haus wie sieht
es denn bei euch aktuell aus die einen
sagten entspannt oder alles ist soweit
gut die anderen sagten an manchen
Stellen ist es schon ein bisschen eng
das Deutschland aus dem Antrag der Union
in dem es überall so eng ist wie in
einer sardinenbuchse ist übertrieben nun
will ich die Situation nicht
bagatisieren wir stehen an manchen
Stellen vor sehr sehr großen
Herausforderungen und da dürfen wir die
Kommunen nicht allein lassen und welche
Überraschung Liebe Union das tun wir
auch nicht wir unterstützen die Länder
und Kommunen finanziell z.B vergangenes
Jahr gab es 4,4 Milliarden Euro diese
Summe haben Sie heute schon heute
häufiger gehört
sind es 2,75 Millionen Milliarden Euro
bis jetzt dieses Geld wird von den Bund
an die Länder gegeben von den Ländern
soll es an die Landkreise weitergegeben
und die werden es und sollen es an die
Kommunen weitergeben
auf Wunsch der Kommunen haben wir sogar
einen
rechtskreiswechsel vollzogen das haben
sie bestimmt auch schon mal gehört weg
von den asylbewerberleistungen die von
den Kommunen getragen werden und hin zu
den Leistungen nach Sozialgesetzbuch
diese Kosten trägt zum größten Teil der
Bund zum Beispiel das Bürgergeld und zu
einem großen Teil eben auch die
Unterkunftskosten und wir kümmern uns
auch wenn es um mehr als nur Geld geht
es gab am 16 Februar ein
flüchtlingsgipfel mit der
bundesinnenministerin nennt sie Feser
dort konnten die Beteiligten ihre
Belange vortragen und es wird einen
weiteren Gipfel geben am 10 Mai das
wissen sie auch liebe Union
den Vorwurf dass wir uns nicht um unsere
Kommunen kümmern weil sie sich also
entschieden zurück in ihrem Antrag
wünschen sie sich die Zahl der
Flüchtlinge die nach Deutschland kommen
zu begrenzen sie wünschen sich eine
Obergrenze dann frage ich sie wie
stellen Sie sich das vor steht da immer
wieder wie wir das von Veranstaltungen
kennen am Eingang und zählt und wenn die
Obergrenze die sie auch nicht definiert
haben dann erreicht es sagen sie sorry
ist voll jetzt geht nicht mehr was sagen
sie dann zu den Menschen die Schutz
suchen die nicht mehr reinkommen ich
sage Ihnen ganz klar mit uns wird es
keine Obergrenze geben denn
Menschlichkeit hat keine Obergrenze
in ihrem Antrag stellen sie fest dass es
zu wenig Wohnraum Kinderbetreuung und
Lehrkräfte medizinisches Personal und
behördliche Kapazitäten gibt Liebe Union
das haben wir auch schon festgestellt
und deswegen arbeiten wir daran wir
versuchen nicht nur nicht alle Probleme
des Landes mit einem Antrag zu lösen wir
gehen wohl bedachte Schritte zum
Beispiel im Bereich der
beschleunigungsverfahren oder der
fachkräfteeinwanderung jeder und jeder
in dieser Fraktionen dieser Regierung
gibt sein Bestes um die aktuelle
Probleme zu lösen
und an dieser Stelle möchte ich mich
auch bei allen Menschen bedanken die
jeden Tag ihr Möglichstes tun um die
Auswirkungen dieses Krieges und dieser
Fluchtbewegung abzufedern so gut es eben
geht sei es in den Kitas oder in den
Schulen sei es in den Ämtern und
Behörden dann gilt allen Ihren Wohnraum
teilen die deutschen Nachhilfe geben und
ihren Beitrag tun sei es nun
hauptamtlich oder ehrenamtlich damit
sich die Menschen die hier fliehen
willkommen fühlen wir wären ihrem Antrag
nicht zustimmen
weg
der nächste Redner in der Debatte kommt
von der Union und ist ihr erster
parlamentarischer Geschäftsführer
Thorsten frei
sehr geehrter Herr Präsident liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen
wir Demokraten brauchen Lösungen sonst
schaffen sie andere die blauen und die
braunen in einigen Jahren des will ich
nicht
das ist eine Äußerung die stammt nicht
von mir sondern die stammt vom
Bürgermeister von Gernsbach aus
Baden-Württemberg übrigens ein
SPD-Mitglied der diese Äußerung bei
unserem kommunalgipfel am 30 März hier
im Paul-Löbe-Haus gemacht hat und damit
auf die Konsequenzen hingewiesen hat was
passiert wenn in der migrationskrise die
Kommunen mit ihren Belastungen alleine
gelassen werden
es ist dort sehr deutlich geworden wir
hatten 400 Teilnehmer Bürgermeister
Oberbürgermeister Landräte Fachleute aus
diesem Bereich und zwar über die
Parteigrenzen hinweg und eine Botschaft
war dass wir auch in Zukunft den
Menschen die Schutz suchen nach
Deutschland kommen Sicherheit und Schutz
bieten möchten aber es ist eben auch ein
Fakt das Ressourcen begrenzt sind dass
viele Kommunen an ihren
Belastungsgrenzen sind und das auch
viele Kommunen über die
Belastungsgrenzen bereits hinausgegangen
sind und wenn Sie sich das einmal
anschauen dann muss man doch sagen die
Probleme sind sehr vielfältiger es geht
darum dass genügend Kitaplätze da sind
es geht um Schulen es geht um fehlendes
Personal es geht um fehlenden Wohnraum
die Ressourcen sind begrenzt und deshalb
müssen wir konstatieren dass Deutschland
bei der Infrastruktur in der Breite auf
einen Zustrom dieses Ausmaßes nicht
vorbereitet ist und das einzige was der
bundesinnenministerin dazu einfällt ist
Humanität kennt keine Obergrenze sie
haben das ebenfalls zitiert verehrte
Frau schierenbecken und ich muss sagen
das ist eine Banalisierung der
Herausforderungen der Kommunen sie
moderieren etwas weg was da ist und ich
will das jetzt gar nicht bewerten
sondern ich will die Bewertung einem
anderen Kommunalpolitiker überlassen
übrigens auch von der SPD vor wenigen
Tagen in der Welt gemacht es ist der
Landrat von Märkisch-Oderland hier in
Brandenburg der diese diesen Hinweis als
das bezeichnet hat was er ist nämlich
als eine moralisierende Scheinheiligkeit
und sonst gar nichts und ich will auch
einen zweiten ich will
auch beweisen ja ich zitiere nur einen
SPD-Politiker und ich will auf einen
zweiten Punkt hinweisen die
bundesinnenministerin tut so als könne
sie bei diesen Problemen gar nicht
helfen sie hat in einem Interview bei
der Funke Mediengruppe noch Anfang
dieses Monats gesagt acht von zehn
geflüchteten seien aus der Ukraine und
diese Zahl ist nachweislich falsch
richtig ist das von denen die zwischen
März letzten Jahres und März diesen
Jahres zu uns gekommen sind 80 Prozent
in den ersten sechs Monaten also bis
August letzten Jahres zu uns gekommen
sind richtig ist das in den ersten drei
Monaten diesen Jahres fast 90.000
Asylanträge gestellt worden sind und
dazu kommen 81.000 Schutzsuchende aus
der Ukraine das bedeutet die Wahrheit
ist die Mehrheit der Menschen die Schutz
suchen zu uns kommen die kommen nicht
aus der Ukraine die kommen aus anderen
Regionen die kommen aus dem ar
Zwischenraum die kommen aus Afrika die
kommen auf aus Asien und was will ich
jetzt damit sagen
erstens es ist bedenklich wenn die
Innenministerin die Zahlen ihres eigenen
Hauses nicht kennt es ist aber
wahrscheinlicher dass sie ganz bewusst
mit der Verzerrung dieser Zahlen die
Öffentlichkeit ihre führen und Täuschen
möchten das ist die Realität und die
Wahrheit ist verehrte Frau
Innenministerin sie haben zwar Amtes
alle rechtlichen und tatsächlichen
Möglichkeiten eine Migrationspolitik zu
machen die den Herausforderungen
wirklich gerecht wird Zwischenfrage
[Gelächter]
vielen Dank Herr Kollege
vielen Dank Herr Kollege sie beziehen
sich ja bei ihren Aussagen auf einen
Zeitraum der jetzt gerade ist wir reden
eigentlich in der Regel von dem Zeitraum
letzten Jahres das heißt wir erzählen
nicht die Wahrheit aber ein Punkt ist
mir dann schon noch mal wichtig sie
haben gerade wir haben gerade sie haben
gerade ich komme sofort dazu sie haben
gerade von den Gruppen gesprochen die
jetzt gerade kürzlich einwandern Syrer
Afghanen erklären Sie uns doch mal wie
wie diese Menschen ablehnen sollen und
wohin diese Menschen dann zurück
abgeschoben werden sollen wenn es nach
ihrer Vorstellung gegen erklären Sie mir
bitte wie das gehen soll
ja Frau Kollegin das erkläre ich Ihnen
gerne das was ich sagen möchte ist dass
wir trennen müssen zwischen denen die
Schutz suchen zu uns kommen und denen
die vorgeben asylberechtigt zu sein aber
entweder oder sowohl eine
Verwaltungsentscheidung wie auch eine
verwaltungsgerichtliche Entscheidung des
Gegenteil festgestellt hat ihre Asyl und
Migrationspolitik läuft darauf hinaus
dass jeder Mensch der es nach
Deutschland geschafft hat hier auch
bleibt und das ist etwas was nicht
akzeptabel ist was zu diesen Problemen
führt und was eben dazu führt dass man
tatsächlich meine Vorredner haben das
ausgeführt man nicht allein mit Geld die
Probleme lösen kann die Kommunen
brauchen Geld und Unterstützung andere
bergäcker hat es sehr deutlich
formuliert aber sie brauchen vor allen
Dingen auch das nicht nur an den
Symptomen herum sondern auch an den
Ursachen und dass wir deshalb eine
konsequente Migrationspolitik machen und
ich darf Ihnen sagen ja
ich darf Ihnen sagen wir haben es in
unserem Antrag niedergelegt was wir für
richtig halten aber wir brauchen gar
nicht so weit gehen es gibt eine
Bund-Länder kommunale Arbeitsgruppe von
der Frau bundesinnenministerin
eingesetzt die hat am 19 April ihren
Ergebnisbericht vorgelegt der Kollege Dr
throm hat vieles davon erwähnt ich kann
nochmal stichwortartig sagen es geht um
sofort wirksamen Grenzschutz es geht
darum auch die Möglichkeit von
Zurückweisungen zu ermöglichen es geht
um die Revitalisierung von ankerzentren
es geht um die Verlängerung der Liste
sicherer Herkunftsstaaten all das sind
Punkte die man machen ja natürlich
Dialoge
frei es gibt noch weitere Nachfragen und
sie können ihre Eltern verdreifachen
wenn das so weitergeht ich will nur
einen Satz sagen sie sind von der grünen
Fraktion im Deutschen Bundestag haben
wir in der letzten Legislaturperiode in
der großen Koalition beschlossen dass
wir Algerien Tunesien Marokko Georgien
zu sichern Herkunftsstaaten machen wir
haben das hier im Deutschen Bundestag
beschlossen sie und ihre Partei haben
sie im Bundesrat aufgehalten und
verhindert letztes Jahr sind allein
10.000 Menschen aus Georgien nach
Deutschland gekommen mit einer
schutzquote von 0,4 Prozent sie sind
dafür verantwortlich dass die Verfahren
zu lange dauern sie sind dafür
verantwortlich dass die Rückführungen
dann auch kaum mehr funktionieren können
sie sind dafür verantwortlich dass alle
die hierher kommen auch hier bleiben
so Herr Kollege ja bitte Frau
Kolleginnen
Dialog sondern sie haben gefragt Herr
Kollege lassen Sie eine weitere
Zwischenfrage der Kolleginnen Junge aus
der Ferne
und dann lasse ich aber keine weiteren
Fragen
danke
selber angesprochen haben ich habe auch
noch mal in ihren Antrag geschaut da
haben sie ja gesagt die meisten haben
offensichtlich keinen Anspruch in
Deutschland auf Schutz und da wollte ich
sie noch mal fragen wie geht das überein
mit der Tatsache und der Realität heute
wird ganz wenig über Realität gesprochen
wie geht das überein mit der Realität
dass sie bereinigte schutzquote über 70%
liegt wie können sie denn vertreten dass
die meisten kein Schutzanspruch haben
ich verstehe es nicht
es kommt natürlich immer genau darauf an
woher die Menschen kommen tatsächlich
ist es so dass in den letzten Wochen die
schutzquote in vielen verschiedenen
Ländern gestiegen ist wir haben
zunehmend Asylanträge aus Syrien aus
Afghanistan aus der Türkei die zunehmend
auch tatsächlich berechtigt sind wir
möchten dass diejenigen die
schutzberechtigt nach Deutschland kommen
auch aufgenommen werden wir möchten dass
die auch integriert werden können und um
das um genau das zu erreichen müssen wir
es schaffen dass diejenigen die nicht
schutzberechtigt sind auch schnell
wieder in ihre Herkunftsländer
zurückkehren
ich hatte keine weiteren Fragen
ich will
zusammenpacken
Gruppe am 19 April vorgelegt haben die
geben eigentlich ein grelles Licht auf
den politischen Bankrott ihrer
Migrationspolitik
sie könnten diese Dinge umsetzen ja sie
könnten diese Dinge umsetzen sie haben
die Instrumente sie haben die Mehrheit
dazu sie haben die Potenziale und eines
muss man doch ganz deutlich sagen eines
muss man ganz deutlich sagen es geht
darum auch in der Zukunft die Akzeptanz
für das Asylrecht aufrecht zu erhalten
und wenn man es nicht schafft mit dem
Asylrecht die irreguläre Migration zu
beenden dann besteht die Gefahr dass die
irreguläre Migration des Asylrecht
beendet und dann haben sie die
Verantwortung dafür herzlichen Dank
vielen Dank Herr Kollege frei
ja viel Emotionen in diesem Thema
Migration und Asyl zwei Anträge der
Oppositionen dazu werden wir beraten
einer gleichschriften namentlich
abgestimmt bereinigen nikols jedenfalls
für die SPD macht jetzt erstmal den Sack
zu er ist der letzte Redner hier zu
diesem Thema sehr geehrter Herr
Präsident liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen
zu Beginn möchte ich noch mal ganz
deutlich sagen weil es mir in der
Debatte doch zu kurz gekommen ist vor
Ort wird großes geleistet und unser Dank
des gesamten Hauses gilt der kommunalen
Familie der ehrenamtlichen Helferinnen
und Helfer vor Ort
und ich bin mir sicher dass auch heute
bei der Debatte auf den besuchertribünen
einige unter uns sind und ihnen gilt
Respekt und Anerkennung und wir stellen
die Belastung überhaupt nicht in Frage
sondern wir suchen gemeinsam nach
Lösungen mit den Kommunen wie der Bund
unterstützen kann das ist Realität
meine Kolleginnen und Kollegen meine
Vorrednerinnen haben schon auf einzelne
Hilfen des Bundes im konkreten Eingang
ich will nur noch mal ganz kurz erwähnen
wir haben 69 000 unterbringungsplätzen
mit der Beamer geschaffen wir haben
dreieinhalb Milliarden im letzten Jahr
2,75 Milliarden in diesem Jahr
bereitgestellt wir haben noch mal für
die Integrationsleistung 9005 Millionen
Euro bereitgestellt das ist mehr als
ursprünglich vorausgesetzt wir haben und
das wurde angesprochen die Ergebnisse in
den arbeitsklamstern die im Integration
im flüchtlingsgipfel eben des
Bundesinnenministeriums angesiedelt
waren viele Ergebnisse erzielt jetzt in
die Umsetzung gehen und es ist doch
richtig dass man erst die Ergebnisse
abwartet sie dann wertet und dann in die
Umsetzung bringen dass digitale
Dashboard haben wir übrigens schon im
März eingeführt wird von der kommunalen
Familie über Partei Grenzen hinweg über
Partei Grenzen hinweg positiv angenommen
und gelobt
Unterstützung muss vor Ort konkret
ankommen da sind wir uns einig und
deswegen verwundert mich diese Debatte
und dieser Antrag denn es geht doch
darum dass die demokratischen Kräfte in
diesem Haus zusammenarbeiten
zusammenhalten müssen um mit den Ländern
gemeinsam die Hilfen des Bundes auch in
die Kommunen zu bringen
und es hilft niemanden es hilft
niemanden Herr frei wenn Sie hier an
dieser Stelle das Trennende suchen wenn
sie dann auch noch obwohl sie es in
ihrem Antrag ja beschreiben Humanität
christliches Menschenbild Nächstenliebe
es steht hier im Antrag ja auch drin
verfolgen zu helfen und ihnen Schutz zu
gewähren ist für uns eine Frage der
humanitären Verantwortlichkeit der
Mitmenschlichkeit und der Nächstenliebe
das christliche Menschenbild gebietet
die Unterstützung für Menschen in Not
aber das christliche Menschenbild kennt
keine Not zweiter Klasse meine Damen und
Herren
ich habe mich auch gewundert es soll
hier um Kommunen gehen das haben sie
zwar alle betont als Redner der Union
aber es kommt kein Mitglied aus den
kommunalausschuss ihrer Fraktion zu Wort
wundert mich schon sehr und noch mal
konkret auf ein Beispiel einzugehen das
sonderaufnahmeprogramm Afghanistan was
zu stoppen sein soll weil es vermeidbare
Belastung sind da frage ich mich ehrlich
wie passt das in ein christliches
Menschenbild erkennen Sie die Not der
Menschen die uns vor allem auch in
Afghanistan unseren Soldaten und
Soldaten geholfen haben erkennen sie das
nicht an treten sie den Rest gegen
begegnen Sie den mit Respekt ich weiß
immer wenn es zu wissen kommt habe ich
einen guten Punkten getroffen
und es wundert mich überhaupt nicht dass
die CDU sich fragt wofür das Sehen im
Namen steht und ihre Mitglieder dazu
befragt hat und die Antworten die haben
mich die Antworten und da sollten sich
vielleicht die Antwort noch mal angucken
die meisten Sachen Freiheit die zweite
sagten die Würde des Menschen zu
schützen des Menschen
die dritte Meister Antwort war Respekt
Anstand und fernes und Respekt Anstand
und fern ist das hätte ich mir in dieser
Debatte gewünscht das wünsche ich mir
auch in Talkshow von Herr März wenn sie
von sozial Tourismus reden damit
erschweren sie die Arbeit von
ehrenamtlichen Helferinnen und Helfern
vor Ort die vergiften das
gesellschaftliche Klima und das ist
schädlich für unser Land
und ihr Parteifreund wüsterte gesagt
dass dieser Antrag seinen Gesellenstück
er seinen Gesellenstück aber nein im
ersten Lehrjahr würde man damit nicht
bestehen mit so einem Antrag deswegen
ist er abzulegen weil wir an der Seite
der Kommunen stehen der ehrenamtlichen
Helferinnen und Helfer vor Ort weil wir
eben die Kommunen dabei unterstützen und
sie können natürlich der Kollege sie
müssen wirklich zum Schluss kommen den
Zwischenrufen der Union zum trotzdem
sind jetzt 30 komme ich komme zum
Schluss mit verlobt wir haben viele
Redezeit unserer Fraktion eingespart für
den Schluss ihr Lieblingsort heute
Realitätsverweigerung dabei gucken sie
in den Spiegel dann sehen sie Realität
verweigungen
Reinkultur Entschuldigung und man sieht
ja eine kleine in Deutschland fahren da
sind die Realität noch ein bisschen
größeren Deutschland fahren da können
sich mal austauschen
vielen Dank Herr Kollege Nicole ist
damit schließe ich die Aussprache wir
kommen zur Abstimmung und dazu liegt mir
an Erklärung nach Paragraph 31 unsere
Geschäftsordnung vor
zunächst rufe ich auf dem
Tagesordnungspunkt 7a Abstimmung in den
Antrag der Fraktion der cdu/csu auf
Drucksache 6740 mit dem Titel für
Humanität und Ordnung in der Asyl und
Flüchtlingspolitik Kommunen in der
Migrationspolitik unterstützen
Forderungen aus dem Kommunen
kommunalgefühl umsetzen die Fraktion der
cocs namentliche Abstimmung verlangt
sie haben zur Abgabe ihrer Stimme nach
Eröffnung der Abstimmung 20 Minuten Zeit
und die Abgeordneten im Saal bitte ich
nach Eröffnung Abstimmung noch für kurze
Zeit für eine weitere Abstimmung hier zu
bleiben ich bitte die Schriftführer nur
die vorgesehen Plätze einzunehmen die
Ohren sind besetzt worden damit der
öffentlichen Namen die Abstimmungen
Antrag auf Drucksache 6.540 die
Abstimmungsrunde werden um
11 Uhr
um 12 Uhr Punkt geschlossen
ja meine Damen und Herren jetzt wird
also namentlich abgestimmt über den
Antrag der Unionsfraktion die Union
fordert unter anderem die Kommunen
dauerhaft finanziell für die Aufgaben
der Migration zu versorgen freiwillige
Aufnahmeprogramme wie etwa in
Afghanistan zu stoppen die ihre
regulären Migration Einheit zu gebieten
und weitere Staaten wie die
Maghreb-Staaten und Georgien als
asylrechtlich sichere Herkunftsstaaten
einzustufen das ist also der Antrag der
Union der jetzt hier von den
Abgeordneten dann namentlich abgestimmt
werden muss es geht in einem weiteren
Antrag der im Antrag der Linken hier
gleich mit der Abstimmung weiter die
Linken dringend in ihrem Antrag auf
einen Paradigmenwechsel die Aufnahme der
Ukraine Flüchtlinge sollen quasi die
Blaupause Pause sein die Menschen sollen
zu Verwandten und Bekannten sofort
ziehen dürfen das Arbeitsverbot soll
aufgehoben werden Zugang zu regulären
Sozialleistungen und uneingeschränkt wir
gesundheitsvor Sorge soll geschaffen
werden